for those of you who are wondering what
the future of the MCU looks like in the
next upcoming years and for those of you
wondering when we're going to see all of
those Fox characters into the MCU
there's some great news today because we
could possibly be getting a solo Doctor
Doom movie how's it going everybody it's
Warren and this is really exciting news
to a lot of people a lot of people got
really excited when there were reports
going around that we could possibly be
getting a Fantastic Four movie in 2022
because Peyton Reed who directed ant-man
and ant-man and the wasp has a script
for a Fantastic Four movie and we have
just learned that there is a script for
a solo Doctor Doom antihero movie and
the writer of the script has recently
met with Marvel Studios as President
Kevin Feige so I'll explain everything
that Noah Halle said about a solo Doctor
Doom film in a recent interview first a
quick reminder about my giveaway at the
450,000 subscriber mark I'll be picking
three winners to each choose one item
from the Marvel Legends series
collection be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you can enter and stick
around to the end to hear more about it
so Noah Halle who is a television writer
a producer a screenwriter he's an author
but he's best known for creating and
writing the Fox television series Fargo
and the Fox Marvel series Legion but
before the Disney Fox merger Noah wrote
a Doctor Doom antihero solo film script
but then the Disney Fox deal happened
and Disney acquired all of the rights to
the Fox characters and then a lot of
people thought well that's it no more
Doctor Doom movie because now Kevin
Feige is in charge of all of these
characters however we have recently
found out that that is not necessarily
the case as Noah has met with Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
and the movie could still possibly get
made just a couple of days ago while
doing an interview with The Hollywood
Reporter Noah brought up dr. doom and
revealed that it still could possibly
get made and that he has recently met
with the president of Marvel Studios
Kevin Feige in the interview he said I
wrote a script about dr. doom an
antihero story I really like and we're
still talking about making it I'm trying
to get out from under this movie I made
and this last season of Legion and Fargo
was coming back up but for better or
worse these are the stories we want to
hear right now I think you can bury your
head in the same
and say that's unfortunate for our
culture because they're simplistic some
people say that I don't look at it that
way I think they are morality tales on a
larger scale and it's better to be a
part of the conversation than pretend
the conversation isn't happening so
right here he blatantly says that
they're still talking about making it
well he can't make it with Fox anymore
legally he cannot make it with Fox they
do not own the rights to Doctor Doom if
there's a Doctor Doom movie it has to be
done by Marvel and Disney and he did go
on to say that he has met with Kevin
Feige recently he goes on to say I did
sit down with Marvel Studios as
President Kevin Feige recently and I
said that I look at myself as sort of
the Marvel R&D department I know the
genre can do all of these amazing things
that the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
doing but my feeling is what else can we
do with it can we make it surreal can we
make it musical not as a gimmick but all
of these techniques are about putting
you into the subjective experience of
these characters so there are two
extremely important things said in this
interview one is that Noah met with the
president of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
the second is that he said we're still
talking about making it we're can only
be a reference to one person Kevin Feige
he is now in charge of all of the Fox
characters that Disney acquired from Fox
so him and his team are the only people
that you can talk to and he mentions
this in the same interview where he said
that he just met with Kevin Feige so it
seems like based off of what Noah said
in this interview they were talking
about a Doctor Doom a solo antihero film
this could be a great way to introduce
dr. doom he could start off as sort of
an antihero much like venom and then
slowly and gradually become the villain
when they introduced the Fantastic Four
and other characters into the MCU again
there has been a report that Marvel
Studios is working on a Fantastic Four
movie but there has also been an
opposite report saying that Marvel is
not working on a Fantastic Four movie
perhaps they're both kind of right
perhaps the movie that they're talking
about is not a Fantastic Four movie but
actually a Doctor Doom movie which is
why the opposite report said that it's
not a Fantastic Four movie it's related
to the Fantastic Four but actually a
Doctor Doom movie
either way it's exciting to finally hear
talk about these Fox characters making
their way to the MCU so be sure to
comment and let me know what you think
about this read
and Doctor Doom news and also comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
LIKE the video and be sure to subscribe
to my channel so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof